all for once Quirk literally just broke
down and stopped working and the main
villain of the entire series might be
dead he might be gone for good mha just
shattered what we thought we knew about
quirks and the final Arc of the story
just entered the most critical stage so
let's get into it you guys know how this
works if you enjoy my videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel attain Quirk Singularity by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now it is
completely free and we are almost there
finally this video will of course
contain MH manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned in the previous chapter we saw
the conclusion of the dark and tragic
all for one and yuichi backstory we saw
how ol for one killed his own brother
possibly by using the Quirk Decay but
once his brother was gone all for one
realized that yoichi's Quirk Factor had
somehow left his body that is when all
for one learned that yoichi had the
power to transfer his Quirk to someone
else and after that all for one spent
generation after generation trying to
retrieve his brother's Quirk The Quirk
known as one for all but all for one
failed Time After Time and eventually he
was soundly defeated by the eighth one
for all user all might back in the
present all for one decided that he had
to take desperate measures in order to
avoid rewinding himself out of existence
before he had a chance to reach
shigaraki so he gambled everything on
one final desperate move he activated
all of his many Quirk factors at once
creating a massive source of power that
hoped would both destroy bakugo and
launch him in shigaraki's Direction at
the same time now in the first
translation we got it seemed like bakugo
was confident that he would overcome all
for one's attack and that he even called
the villain stupid for thinking that
this was enough to defeat him however
the official VI translation translated
this last part as bakugo saying to
himself oh some genius I am how could I
ever hope to beat that which is kind of
the opposite of what the original
translation implied that said bakugo is
still smirking as he says this so he
still got that bakugo confidence and you
know that he's not going to run away
from this he's going to keep fighting no
matter what the latest chapter begins
with bakugo's life kind of like quickly
flashing before his eyes we see him
being born with his mother and father
looking upon baby bakugo lovingly and
then we see him in his childhood back
when he still used to be mean to deu but
then in the present moment bakugo
declares that he won't mess with isuku
anymore which kind of just confirms the
character growth that we've been seeing
from bakugo for a long time now sure
bakugo still has that crazy fiery
attitude but he's not nearly as much of
a raging a-hole as he used to be now you
might be thinking oh is bakugo's life
flashing before his eyes because he's
about to die again like for the third
time no he's not we can all relax just
drop a like right now for bakugo not
dying again and let's keep going bakugo
in the present moment prepares to take
on the brunt of all for once's ultimate
attack the attack he launched in the
previous chapter which involves
activating all of his many Quirk factors
at once but then bakugo suddenly reveals
that he had an epic trick up his sleeve
all along as bakugo shouts burst that
massive clump of Quirk factors that all
for one generated suddenly explodes
which leads the clump to fall to the
ground before it can reach katsky sweaty
boy bakugo then reveals that earlier on
he had covered up the explosive sweat
drops coming from his body with normal
sweat drops in order to prevent them
from being destroyed by the rain then at
the end of chapter 406 he was able to
get those sweat drops inside ins of all
for one's mouth this is why he was now
able to activate a massive explosion
inside of all for one because the
villain unknowingly consumed bakugo's
explosive sweat earlier on so two things
here first we have bakugo being able to
activate his explosion remotely from a
distance which is something new and very
cool obviously then there's the fact
that this was a really smart strategic
move by bakugo but at the same time it
is incredibly gross so I don't know if I
should praise him or be disgusted by him
or maybe a bit of both I I guess anyway
all for one is shocked that bakugo was
able to get one over on him like this
but bakugo explains that he's always
been pretty smart and unlike all for one
he doesn't need multiple quirks just his
one single Quirk explosion is plenty
that's why they call him great explosion
murder God baby now all for one realizes
that his entire ultimate final attack
was just ruined by the fact that he
decided to drink bakugo's explosive
sweat and in order for the villain to
overcome bakugo and reach shigaraki he
would need to activate the whole attack
again obviously all for one doesn't have
that much left in the tank so he is
absolutely Furious that bakugo managed
to defy him all for one screams at
sweaty boy bakugo that this is his story
and bakugo is just a side character but
katsky isn't intimidated at all and he
proceeds to attack the villain with
Howitzer impact and as this Furious and
explosive battle continues all for one
suddenly realizes that there is a
serious problem with his Quirk all the
different Quirk factors that the villain
is normally able to control are not
behaving as they should all for one
starts to think that maybe his body has
already become too small and weak and so
he is no longer able to control the vast
amounts of power that the Quirk all for
one possesses we suddenly get a glimpse
of the vestage world within the All For
One Quirk this is of course similar to
the vestage world within one for all
except all for one's vestage world is a
lot busier because it includes a lot
more Quirk factors that the villain has
stolen over the course of many
generations interestingly enough all for
one himself now appears as a small child
inside his own vestage world which
indicates that just like his physical
body his Quirk factor is also getting
smaller and weaker we then see the
vestage of hawks and as we know he is
there because all for one stole Hawk's
Quirk after the battle at Goa Mountain
the vestage of hawks explains that all
for one is now too weak and too
emotional to control the other Quirk
factors and so Hawk's vestage has been
able to gather the other vestages that
came from the other stolen Quirk factors
some of these these vestages appear to
be fans of hawks While others are just
angry at all for one for having stolen
them from their original owners and so
Hawks seems to be leading some sort of
internal Rebellion Against All For One
within his own vestage world within his
own body and his own Quirk Hawk says
that in the end all foran's precious new
vessel the one who was groomed from
childhood to become all foran's new host
ended up being his greatest downfall
back in the outside world all might
states that all the physical and
psychological damage that all for one
has sustained over the course of this
final Arc is finally taking its toll it
is finally paying off and having a real
effect on the villain bakugo counters
all for one's claim that he is the
protagonist by shouting this is our
story and he smashes the villain into
the ground we see that bakugo's parents
are anxiously watching the battle
everyone is waiting to see what happens
next and bakugo seems to imply that this
is it after launching another powerful
explosion at over one bakugo says that
he would never have been able to defeat
All For One by himself but with the
combined efforts of everyone at gunga
and all might and everyone else who
helped it seems that all for one has
finally been defeated for good he is
losing on the inside as the vestages of
the quirks he stole in the past are
rebelling against him and he is now too
weak to control them he is also losing
on the outside as bakugo continues to
slam him with blow after blow and
explosion after explosion and it really
does seem like this is it this is the
moment that all for one Falls and
shigaraki becomes the final boss of the
series I mean there could theoretically
be some massive twist coming some secret
power that all for one has that no one
knows about yet or like Kuro gidi just
shows up out of nowhere and saves him
but in all likelihood this is it for all
for one either he will become
incapacitated and unable to fight or he
will rewind himself out of existence
either way I think that we are about to
permanently shift our Focus away from
overan and towards the final epic
showdown between awakened shigaraki and
deu however we do have to acknowledge
that if this ends up being the end of
all for one there are still some
unresolved questions concerning the arch
villain that need to be resolved somehow
are we going to get confirmation that
shigaraki was actually born quirkless
and that all for one secretly gave him
the K which led to little ten kosimo
accidentally killing his own family and
becoming a psychologically scarred mess
that all for one was able to take
advantage of are we going to learn more
about the process of creating nomu did
uo really bring all for one back from
the dead like the last chapter seemed to
suggest
and if so then did he use the same
process that he used to bring oboro
Shuma back from the dead in order to
create kurogiri the kuroi plot point is
still not yet resolved so are we going
to get a resolution now that all for one
seems to be getting ready to make his
exit or are we going to get something
later on finally after all that fan
speculation is there going to be any
sort of connection between all for one
and the fact that deku's father has been
completely miia throughout the entire
series there are so many theories
theories that all for one is literally
deku's dad theories that deku's Dad was
killed by All For One theories that
deku's Dad is a villain working for all
for one and so on Hoshi promised that we
would meet deku's Dad before the series
ended so is it finally that time or is
he going to keep teasing us I need to
know Hoshi come on throw us a bone I
mean if my dad went home for milk and he
didn't come back for like 2 years I
would have a lot of questions so
hopefully we're going to get some
freaking answers soon what do you guys
think did bakugo just defeat all for one
is all for one's Quirk broken and is is
there a way for these stolen Quirk
factors to be returned to their original
users I definitely want Hawks to get his
Quirk back so I really want to see what
happens now that the Ala 1 Quirk seems
to be breaking apart don't forget to
leave your feedback down in the comments
below if you're looking for more epic
mha videos to watch next check out my
full mha playlist link on screen and
down in the description if you enjoyed
this video you know what to do leave a
quick like to let me know and if you
want to help this channel attain Quirk
Singularity by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a big favor and
subscribe right
now